I forgot.
That's the Joe Rogan experience.
This modernity,
I mean,
the way human beings represents sexuality or the way sexuality is represented.
Um,
what's wrong with it?
Like what,
what are the,
what are the key things that stand out as an evolutionary biologist?
Um,
well let me try it and experiment with you this.
Okay.
This is,
uh,
I'm concerned this isn't gonna work,
but I hope,
I hope it does.
Even if it doesn't work,
go to work.
Okay.
Um,
I would like to try and experiment with you as a,
a red blooded male.
Okay.
I would like you to conjure the image in your mind of a woman who is not
beautiful,
but it's hot.
Okay.
Can you do it?
Sure.
Okay.
Can you conjure the image of a woman who is beautiful but not hot?
Yes,
no problem.
No problem.
Me Either.
Um,
this I think actually is a window into much that is wrong with what we think
about human sexuality.
I think most people,
if you ask them without doing that little experiment to conjure a,
or to define what,
what it is for somebody to be hot,
you would get answers and people would tell you that hot was sort of like the
height of beauty,
right?
Which is very frightening.
If that's true because hotness Wayne's with age,
it deteriorates.
It just can't help it.
The discovery that beauty actually is a different parameter tells a whole
different story about what's going on with us.
People,
with men and with women.
And I think both men and women are confused by this.
Um,
so if it is true,
and I,
I mean,
I know it is true.
I can look inside my own mind and I can say that at least for some men it is
true that beauty and hotness are almost uncorrelated.
There are people who have both traits,
but I,
uh,
I have no trouble seeing that image of a woman who was hot but not the least bit
beautiful.
And I know lots of women who are beautiful and not hot.
And I also,
if I take the category of women who are beautiful but not hot,
um,
there are a lot of older women in it,
right?
I know women in their sixties and seventies who have poise have aged gracefully.
They're gray as can be.
They may be wrinkled,
but if you talk to them,
one does have the sense I'm talking to a beautiful person,
right?
And I'm not,
I'm not being modeling here.
If it was just a simple fact that both beauty and hotness wane with age,
I would say so.
But it is not the case.
So what's going on?
Why do we have these two categories and why do we assume,
I mean if you look at advertising,
you will get the message that hotness is where it's at,
right?
Hi.
This is the thing.
It's the only standard possible.
It's the only standard.
And so women are aspiring to it and then they're fighting it as it wanes and all
of this.
And um,
here,
here's what I suspect is up because males are males.
They have,
I want to say they have to reproductive strategies.
Really,
they have three reproductive strategies.
And one of them is,
uh,
so awful that it's really just unpleasant,
even entered into the discussion.
But
Yup.
Yeah.
So the first reproductive strategy that men have,
the one that would generally have succeeded and not by the way we can talk about
monogamy versus polyamory and all of that at some point,
but,
uh,
I'm not saying anything that is inherent,
it's not inherently about monogamy.
The way males have typically reproduced is they have invested in their offspring
and the mothers of their offspring.
That's the Goto mechanism for reproducing as a human.
Why?
Because human babies are so needy that one person trying to raise them on their
own is hobbled by just the sheer difficulty of trying to manage an infant and a
toddler while trying to accomplish the other things of being a person.
So let me just add here.
The idea that monogamy has been ubiquitous throughout human history is not
completely accepted,
uh,
but that there is good evidence for it and a lot of fronts.
And one of the points against it is that we remain somewhat sexually dimorphic.
That men are on average,
a bit taller,
a bit more muscle,
much more muscular.
Um,
but that we are so much less sexually dimorphic then even our ancestors,
um,
beef in more recent times then when we were,
we shouldn't read most recent common ancestor with chimps that we are moving
towards a more monogamous situation.
So just I think,
I think you said something that was unclear at the beginning.
There has been a lot of polygyny where one male has multiple females in human
history.
Probably the majority of human cultures have been polygynous.
Yes,
majority of people on Earth today belong to cultures that are at least nominally
monogamous.
And we should talk about what that shift is and what it means to us and what's
desirable and all of that.
But the basic point that human babies are so expensive and difficult to raise
that,
um,
you need a team to do it.
And you know,
in part this is a chicken and egg question is not a good term because it's quite
clear which came first.
But,
um,
the,
this is a situation where the,
when you have a team,
you can also afford to have a baby that's more needy.
And there there's nothing good about a needy baby,
but there is something good about what you can get.
If you can tolerate a needy baby,
you can get a baby that's a lot more nuanced when it grows up.
So males,
I have traditionally invested in offspring,
um,
but a male who is investing in their offspring,
should they happen on an opportunity in which a female who is fertile and
capable of producing an offspring,
it does not require commitment from them in order to have sex.
That's an evolutionary bargain.
A male who can either convince a female or finds a female who's willing to
produce a baby but not expect any support in return.
That's such a power.
It's like winning the lottery evolutionarily.
So it would have almost never happened in history because women,
because babies are so expensive,
are wired to avoid this like the plague.
You don't want to get stuck raising a baby on your own if you could,
through committing to somebody,
get a partner in raising an offspring.
So how does birth control factor into the,
well,
we'll get there in a second,
but let's just get the two strategies on the table.
Males in general have succeeded reproductively by investing in their offspring
and their offsprings.
Mothers when they have the opportunity to produce offspring with no commitment,
they have a hard time resisting that opportunity because it's such an
evolutionary win.
But that doesn't mean it would have been very common in history because females
would avoid it.
So my,
I can't look away from hot is about that second strategy,
right?
So hot is this channel that men can,
they,
they are wired in such a way that they actually,
we've been robbed of every useful term.
They are triggered by the sight of a woman who is broadcasting hotness.
All right.
And,
um,
so anyway,
the,
the thing that I think is most important about this is we now live in a culture
where we have advertisers essentially creating a kind of insecurity because
insecurity causes people to spend money they otherwise wouldn't.
That insecurity has women trying to capture male attention by broadcasting
hotness,
which of course works because men have a hard time ignoring hotness.
But what I think women often don't understand is that getting a man's attention
by broadcasting hotness has him in the frame of mind of this second reproductive
strategy.
And it is actually counterproductive to getting his attention for the first
reproductive strategy because men,
um,
have historically,
this is by the way,
this is where I'm going to get in huge trouble with people because this is going
to sound like an accusation.
Really.
I'm just trying to describe what has been and then we can talk about what we
should do about it.
But,
um,
a woman who values herself highly in reproductive terms will not leap on,
uh,
a sexual opportunity just because it's available.
Because what's at stake is so great.
Historically for women,
this is not true anymore because of birth control.
But historically it would be true that a sexual interaction is basically baby
roulette and baby roulette is a dangerous game to play.
So,
and so we get at some of what's true underneath the stereotype of the Madonna
whore dichotomy,
uh,
that neither of those words is quite right because no one wants a Madonna.
No one wants a virgin is a life partner,
right?
You want it to have a vibrant sexual relationship with your life partner,
but the,
are you triggering the hotness?
Can I get a baby out of you and never see it?
Um,
strategy and men or are you triggering the,
Oh my God,
you're gorgeous.
And I feel like we could do this together.
I hate to interrupt you,
but you got to pull this thing close to,
sorry,
just move that sucker around.
So it's so it's comfortable where you're sitting.
How about that?
It's very different.
It sounds okay in our ears,
but it's very sick.
Tenancy audio.
Sorry.
Perfect nugget.
So,
so anyway,
then the Madonna whore complex,
which is this famous thing,
isn't it?
The paradox that we are led to believe men are interested in,
you know,
as Heather points out,
Madonna and whore or the wrong terms,
they're very charged,
but men are interested in both of these reproductive strategies,
but they are not interested.
They're not paradoxically searching for them in the same individual.
Okay.